CONGRESSIONAL ACTION TO DO IT.
>> Harris: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS YET TO CALL
IT A  CRISIS.
MAYORKAS SAID WE’RE ON PACE TO
ENCOUNTER MORE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER THAN WE
HAVE IN THE PAST 20 YEARS.
SARAH SANDERS SERVED AS WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NOW RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR IN ARKANSAS.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR RUN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, SARAH.
SO IMPORTANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS.
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN THE LAST
PRESS SECRETARY FOR A WHITE
HOUSE TO DEAL WITH SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS LIKE WHAT WE’RE
DEALING WITH BUT I’VE HEARD
EVEN YOU SAY IT’S NOT THE SAME.
HOW.
>> WELL, LET’S LOOK AT THE
SITUATION CERTAINLY I THINK THE
MEDIA SERVED AS THE PROPAGANDA
ARM FOR THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN AND
THEY’RE DOING THE EXACT SAME
THING IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
THEY CONTINUE TO PROP UP THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEY AREN’T HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE FACTS ARE CLEAR.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP INSTITUTED
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY AND
PUT UP A BORDER WALL, IT WAS
EFFECTIVE AND IT WORKED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
ADMINISTRATION HAS ACTUALLY
CAUSED A HUMANITARIAN AND
NATIONAL CRISIS AT OUR BORDER
BY OPENING THEM UP AT A TIME
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE FIGHTING TO
KEEP OUR SCHOOLS, OUR
BUSINESSES, AND OUR CHURCHES
CLOSED, THEY ARE COMPLETELY
OPENING OUR BORDER.
IT IS A TOTAL DISGRACE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHEN YOU
OPEN THE BORDERS AND YOU INVITE
PEOPLE TO COME HERE ILLEGALLY,
THEY DO.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT WE’RE
SEEING HAPPEN ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AND PEOPLE ARE FLOODING
IN.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY OR
CAPACITY TO HANDLE IT.
IT IS CREATING A MASSIVE
HUMANITARIAN AND NATIONAL
CRISIS AT THE BOARD AND A
DIRECT HULT OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S FAILURE TO
DEAL WITH IT AND ALLOW IT TO
CONTINUE.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET TO
THIS SO WE CAN WATCH IT
TOGETHER.
CURRENT WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY JEN PSAKI YESTERDAY
WAS ASKED IF THERE IS A BOARD
ARE DISASTER GIVING BIDEN
HAVING CALLED FEMA TO DEAL WITH
THE MIGRANTS.
>> THE LAST ADMINISTRATION LEFT
US A DISMANTLED AND UNWORKABLE
SYSTEM AND LIKE ANY OTHER
PROBLEM, WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SOLVE IT.
I KNOW WE ALWAYS GET INTO THE
FUN OF LABELS AROUND HERE.
OUR FOCUS IS ON SOLUTIONS.
THIS IS A BIG CHALLENGE AND IT
IS CERTAINLY A REFLECTION OF
USING EVERY LEVER OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP
ADDRESS THAT.
>> Harris: SARAH SANDERS, WHAT
IS YOUR REACTION TO JEN PSAKI?
>> SHE IS ENTITLED TO HER OWN
OPINION BUT NOT ENTITLED TO HER
OWN FACTS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION’S
POLICY THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY AND BORDER WALL AND
OTHER MEASURES THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PUT INTO PLACE
WERE WORKING AT SECURING OUR
BORDER.
LOOK, WE WANT PEOPLE TO COME
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
WE WANT THEM TO DO SO LEGALLY
AND THROUGH THE CORRECT PROCESS.
THEY NOT ONLY OPENED OUR
BORDERS BUT ENCOURAGED PEOPLE
TO COME TO OUR COUNTRY AGAIN AT
A TIME WHEN THEY ARE SHUTTING
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY DOWN.
THEY ARE OPENING UP OUR BORDER.
THEY CREATED THIS PROBLEM BY
THEIR FAILURE TO UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION AT THE BORDER AND
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO MAKE IT
WORSE BY NOT ADDRESSING IT.
THEY HAVE COMPLETE AND TOTAL
FAILURE RIGHT NOW AT THE BORDER
AND I THINK KEVIN MCCARTHY IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
IF THEY WANT TO DEAL WITH SOME
OF THE CRISIS GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY IT IS TO GO DOWN THERE,
LOOK THE PEOPLE KNEE EYE AND
UNDERSTAND THE CRISIS AND
PROBLEM THEY HAVE CREATED IN
OUR SOUTHERN STATES AND AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Harris: DO YOU THINK THAT
THE BIDEN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GET HARASSED LIKE YOU DID?
YOU WERE IN A RESTAURANT WITH
YOUR FAMILY.
THIS WAS GOING ON JUST TO
REMIND EVERYBODY AND YOU ARE
GOOD SPIRITED ABOUT IT BUT IT
WAS WORRISOME.
DO YOU THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
>> FRANKLY, I HOPE NOT.T.
THAT’S NOT WHO WE ARE AS A
COUNTRY.
I DIDN’T LIKE IT WHEN IT
HAPPENED TO ME AND I DON’T WANT
TO SEE THAT HAPPEN TO SOMEBODY
ELSE.
I WANT TO SEE THEM HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
I WANT TO SEE THE MEDIA ASK
THEM HARD QUESTIONS.
I WANT TO SEE THEM ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM AND FIX IT.
I DON’T WISH WHAT HAPPENED TO
ME ON EVEN MY WORST ENEMY.
IN FACT, I THINK THAT’S THE
OPPOSITE OF HOW WE SHOULD DEAL
WITH SOMETHING.
I DO WANT THEM TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM.
I WANT THEM TO RECOGNIZE THAT
IT EXISTS, WHICH I THINK IS
SOMETHING THEY HAVE FAILED TO
DO SO FAR.
I WANT THEM TO TAKE STEPS TO
FIX IT AND I WANT THE MEDIA TO
CONTINUE TO ASK HARD QUESTIONS
AND HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE UNTIL
THEY DO IT.
>> Harris: I WANT THE PRESIDENT
TO START TALKING TO THE MEDIA,
THAT WOULD HELP DO ALL THOSE
THINGS YOU JUST MENTIONED.
CAN WE GET PERSON ONE TO ANSWER
QUESTION ONE?
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS TOURING
AMERICA TODAY CELEBRATING HIS
MASSIVE SPENDING LEGISLATION
BUT YET TO FACE THE MUSIC WITH
REPORTERS IN A SOLO NEWS
CONFERENCE.
I WAS JUST MENTIONING, THE DAY
COUNT, 55 DAYS.
BIDEN’S APPARENT UNWILLINGNESS
TO TAKE ON THE PRESS COMES AS
SOME DEMOCRATS ARE REPORTEDLY
FRUSTRATED WITH HIS RESPONSE
WITHIN THEIR OWN PARTY TO THE
BORDER DISASTER.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" PUT IT
THIS WAY, CENTRIST DEMOCRATS
ARE NERVOUS ABOUT ATTACKS
CASTING THEM AS SOFT ON BORDER
SECURITY.
LIBERALS AND IMMIGRATION
ACTIVIST ARE SOUNDING ALARMS
HOW MIGRANTS ARE TREATED AND SO
FAR NO DATE HAS BEEN SET BY THE
WHITE HOUSE AFTER THE PROMISE
THAT WE WOULD GET THAT SOLO
NEWS CONFERENCE WITH THE
PRESIDENT BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH.
SARAH.
>> IT’S NOT SURPRISING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOES NOT HAVE A
GREAT STORY TO TELL RIGHT NOW.
HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS ALLOWED
THE BORDER CRISIS TO FLOURISH
CREATING A HUMANITARIAN AND
NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
THEY ALSO HAD SLAMMED THIS
LEGISLATION THROUGH AND THEY DO
NOT HAVE A GOOD ABILITY TO
DEFEND WHAT THEY’VE DONE.
CERTAINLY I THINK ALL AMERICANS
AND THOSE REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS WANT TO SEE RELIEF
PROVIDED WHERE IT IS NEEDED.
BUT ONLY 9% OF THAT LEGISLATION
ACTUALLY DEALS WITH COVID
RELIEF.
THE OTHER 91% IS A LIBERAL
AGENDA THAT THEY ARE MASKING IN
COVID RELIEF.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
DEFEND THAT AND WHY YOU DON’T
SEE PRESIDENT BIDEN ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
IT IS EITHER HE DOESN’T KNOW
HOW OR HE DOESN’T HAVE A GOOD
STORY TO TELL.
I THINK THAT’S WHY YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO SEE HIM IN HIDING
AND THE MEDIA IS SITTING BACK
AND ALLOWING IT TO HAPPEN.
THEY WOULD NEVER HAVE ALLOWED
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO GO THIS LONG
WITHOUT ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
DONALD TRUMP WAS THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE PRESIDENT IN HISTORY.
HE TOOK QUESTIONS ALMOST DAILY.
AND THE PRESS HELD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT.
THEY NEED TO TAKE THE SAME
STANDARD WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND MAKE HIM ANSWER HARD
QUESTIONS.
>> Harris: WE’LL SEE WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET THAT DONE.
MY LIST GROWS LONGER EVERY DAY.
WE NEED TO GET STARTED.